des taxis volant à l'énergie électrique
des avions fonctionnant avec des moteurs
hybrides des innovations présentées sur
ce salon du bourget 2019 par
l'équipementier aéronautique français
le groupe safran des technologies en
évolution permanente
on peut pas dire aujourd'hui que
l'airbus a320 que vous prenez pour aller
en vacances sera totalement électrique
dans dix ans certainement pas en
revanche pour des véhicules beaucoup
plus petit donc on entend beaucoup
parler
la mobilité à la demande mais aussi des
avions comme hutter aux régionaux de
quelques dizaines de passagers
eh bien les technologies pour être prête
beaucoup plus vitry le projet du moteur
électrique et hybride est développée
notamment par safran tech basée à magny
les hameaux
un centre de recherche du groupe
inauguré en 2015 alors on travaille
effectivement sur comment rendre un
moteur plus électriques pour les avions
de transport de passagers
ces technologies là permettent des gains
de carburant mais aussi des gains
d'efficacité en opération des coups de
coude usage par l'électrification et
l'assistance électrique en fait du
moteur classique c'est l'incontournable
du salon du bourget le rafale l'avion de
combat de l'armée française omnirôle
développé par dassault aviation
un appareil composé de pièces fabriquées
notamment à saint quentin en yvelines
c'est le cas de cette antenne l'usiné
par le groupe bauer et sa filiale
jacques loupé cli en collaboration avec
thales ce sont des systèmes de détection
ce qu'on appelle de la guerre
électronique et donc ils permettent de
détecter des cibles
pour protéger en fait de raffard et de
systèmes da nous sommes en pleine
croissance
actuellement la en l'espace de cinq ans
bo n a doublé et nous avons la même
perspective pour les 5 10 prochaines
années
au total près de 60 entreprises
aéronautiques sont implantés sur saint
quentin en yvelines pour quatorze mille
emplois dans le secteur